because China is that communist state  everything that you do is monitored and  tracked if you say the wrong thing you  like the wrong thing on social media  then you're given a credit score and if  your credit score Falls too low because  you know you held that wrong opinion  then your money will be refused so you  and I simply having this conversation  could potentially bring our social  credit score a little bit lower so I'd  like to buy a plane ticket back to  England so I can come on your show or I  can see my family my cbdc could get  refused because I had this conversation  with you bringing my social credit score  lower